hello everyone and welcome back to
versus on that most special of occasions
for today i mark ellis finally have the
privilege of hosting the most coveted
match-up in the history of this program
which could possibly be the greatest
battle in the history of entertainment
no it's not sly versus arnie we already
did that and it's not meryl streep
taking on every other oscar nominee all
at once it's not even alien versus
predator although one of those creatures
may be familiar with one of our
competitors today stretch your legs and
shave your coma beard because today on
versus it's jean-claude van damme taking
on steven seagal two macho martial arts
maestros will go mano amano over five
grueling rounds all judged by a guy who
once took three weeks of karate lessons
back in sixth grade mainly because there
was a kfc on the way home from the james
city county rec center yeah you jump
around a little bit is that it here's
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three best moments
round four get in the ring and then
we'll do a wild card round to settle the
score once and for all we could arrange
this another way we've been waiting our
whole collective lives to see these two
fellas go at it on the big screen you
don't believe that for a minute or in a
ring in vegas or the back alley you need
what i tell you you need look i don't
care how it gets done i'm just happy
that after hundreds of episodes of this
show i finally have been blessed with a
match-up that i'm actually somewhat
qualified to judge i love these guys
grew up watching their movies and broke
many pieces of household furniture
trying to replicate their on-screen
moves let's get back to work but enough
about my morning are you ready to go
it's a double impact as two above the
law street fighters take the maximum
risk of being under siege because
there's nowhere to run both pandam and
seagal have the fire down below to
compete in a blood sport and the lion
hard to stand on deadly ground and it
will be up to me to make the executive
decision of who is the one true
universal soldier and who is marked for
death
welcome to the jungle let's get it on
round one box office before the days of
red box dvds and streaming services
jean-claude van damme and steven seagal
both made movies that not only were
released in theaters but people actually
showed up in droves to see them back in
the 80s muscle-bound superstars like
stallone and schwarzenegger ruled the
multiplex but then american audiences
seemed to desire more than just who
could wield the biggest weapon while
uttering a zany one-liner you got it
they wanted what fans around the world
were enjoying thanks to the likes of
martial artists like bruce lee and
jackie chan it was high kick time that
we got some badassery with some
professional level brawlers here in the
united states van damme burst on the
scene first with 1988's bloodsport after
bit parts in films like monaco fever and
a gift worthy appearance in breaking
that was the big misunderstanding you
know jcvd who was born jean-claude
camille vancois van verenberg or j
ccfvv for short whoa
take it easy
became an international star in the
first of many films that saw him get
sand in his eyes courtesy of an
unchivalrous opponent
[Music]
bloodsport would go on to earn an
impressive profit in the form of been
adjusted for inflation 26 million dollar
hull his bank ability would further be
buoyed in the next decade with films
like 1991's double impact which earned
63 million dollars 1992's universal
soldier that accrued 80 million bucks
and 1993's all-time classic hard target
which snake punched its way to a 70
million dollar run
that's right by this time there was
another a-list badass on the scene some
dude with a stone cold stare named
steven seagal hello
born jonathan livingston seagull
i'm so stupid but it's funny his debut
film was a hit thanks to his precision
level aikido and expert level karate
that was 1988's above the law and it did
42 million dollars worth of business you
guys think you're above the law
you ain't about wine the trend of steven
seagal three word titles continue to
earn bread with folks like out for
justice and march for death both being
considered box office successes
both segal and van dam would see their
biggest box office wins as a lead
attraction shortly thereafter for stevie
he's gonna get mad if i call him that
right
it was a 1992 die hard on a boat
blockbuster under siege in which his
casey ryback was just a cook on a navy
ship overrun by terrorists including
tommy lee jones and gary busey do i look
like i need a psychological evaluation
now luckily this cook was also a navy
seal and the buds training paid off
under siege would go on to rake in 184
million dollars
1996's sequel dark territory is one of
the greatest awful additions to a
franchise ever but we were still fooled
into contributing 105 million dollars
before we knew any better nobody beats
me in the kitchen sandwiched in between
sieges was van damme's best single year
as the headliner of an action film
1994's double team well double team
wasn't one of the movies it was street
fighter and time cop and they brought in
a combined 174 million dollars and one
of those two films still holds up
you didn't mention you could read here's
where this round really becomes a tough
call van damme's biggest box office hits
have been as part of an ensemble in
family films albeit ones that feature
plenty of mighty martial arts mayhem
kung fu panda two did 190 million
dollars and part three brought in
another 153 million dollars it's a great
trilogy and yes i saw those sequels
primarily to enjoy my guy jcvd as a
conniving crocodile thanks steven seagal
has had his successes in a large cast as
was the case with 1995's executive
decision and it's 117 million dollar
take but he's largely a lone wolf and he
even famously turned down an offer to
appear in the aging action star legacy
franchise the expendables but overall
stevo he's really gonna hate that boasts
an impressive average his films have
done a total of 1.03
billion dollars at the domestic box
office making for a per movie average of
79 million bucks
van damme has a higher total haul in his
corner as his flicks add up to 1.22
billion dollars however he needed a few
more talkies or maybe they should be
called kikis to get there his average
multiplex performance is 58 million
dollars so it's a close match here and
the stats can be flexed in either
direction but what wins me over for
seagal here is that he didn't have the
luxury of the kung fu panda jungle nuts
in his quarter it's steven seagal that
wins round one and he goes up one to
nothing i'm thrilled to death to hear
that round two tomato meter slash
audience score all right time to come
clean and bear my soul as i do so often
on this show i don't think this is a
good time now it's gonna be a tough
round too because fellas the critics may
not be in your corner now usually when
it comes to the tomato meter i like to
reference the classic letter grading
system we all learned in school the last
time i checked seagal wasn't in the
godfather and van damme narrowly missed
being in predator so neither one of
these dudes is vying for a tomato meter
valedictorian
ditch me
thus we're going to use the old school
pass fail system and i pray that each
action icon has at least one movie that
could possibly get them into a junior
college anything is possible all right
boys who's up first this
i'm trained for hey it's steven seagal
confident as always and why not he has
some fresh movies to brag about
three to be exact executive decision
despite its inclusion of fresh tastic
performers like america's movie star
kurt russell and america's leading lady
howie berry it's just barely fresh at 65
percent but that still passes as does
machete which he's kind of in at 72
percent but his seaways were working and
the tomato sauce was good
until gary busey spit in it
little flavor and his number one flick
on the meter day tomato is under siege
at 79
way to go steve but now the sobering
reminder that seagal alone has 49 movies
that
the critics couldn't even be bothered to
review what kind of babbling bull is
this which is still better than a zero
percent he's actually got a couple that
actually scored zero percent with
contract to kill and the non-jackie
chant pierce brosnan film the foreigner
cold as ice is steven seagal's tomato
meter average he's at 29
per film but hey this next decade could
turn it all around
that would be nice all right jean-claude
we praised and buried your arch nemesis
so now it's your turn and we got more
zero percents dr brussels mussels has
five zero percent movies on his tomato
meter including desert heat which i
loved and death warrant which i rented
approximately 17 times growing up the
good news is van damme only has 20
movies that the critics avoided
altogether and the even better news he
can walk into any gym around the world
and drop the mic by proclaiming that he
has eight movies that are tomato meter
fresh come on lionheart never all right
lionheart's only at 31 percent but kung
fu panda three's at 87 percent and jc vd
is it 84 percent way to go jean claude
his villain has turned in expendables
too is also fresh at 67 percent and just
missing the mark is hard target at 56
and sudden death at an even 50 percent
where is time cop
well it's 45 but his audience score is
only 36 percent great
with thespians like these and the
cinematic gold they've spun out over the
years i thought the audience score would
rebound both gentlemen's emotions
but no steven seagal's average movie on
the audience score side of the tracks
it's the exact same as the tomatoey side
29
however van damme improves upon his 38
tomato meter average with a 40 audience
score per film
hard target is still rotten here but
bloodsport makes it into fresh territory
with a 74
team chance pedro gets to win in round
two and we got us a tied ball game no no
it's
dukes
round three best moments
all right now i'm not just excited to
get to this round i'm still a little
perturbed at you at me at all of us i
understand that these flicks were never
intended to be critical darlings but
those audience score numbers i feel like
maximus and gladiator are you not
entertained were you expecting citizen
kane hard target features wilfred
brimley with a cajun accent these mans
will chase after you
he mad at you for business or pleasure
hard to kill features steven seagal
waking up from an eight-year coma and
like the next day he's breaking bad guy
limbs these movies were meant to be
preposterous under siege has gary busey
as an out of his mind villainous genius
outstanding all right that one i can buy
but regardless ridiculous though many of
these films may be there mighty some
feature some of the greatest action ever
put to celluloid and this round will be
won by whichever actor had more of a
counter-splitting arm-shattering
snake-biting good time and if it is a
tie at the end of this round i'll
probably throw in some of the silliest
moments any action movie has ever had
all right fellas who's in the ring first
here comes steven seagal who like i said
woke up from a coma ready to seek
revenge on all those who ever wronged
him he escaped from his hospital bed
goes through a glorious training montage
and oh did i mention he managed to get a
beautiful doctor to fall in love with
him while he was laying comatose no to
all you fellas trying way too hard at
the club less is more out for justice
continues the trend of seagull crushing
skulls and in this case blowing a dude's
leg clean off without so much as
breaking a sweat
maybe it was in seagal's contract that
he didn't want to so much take his one
punch in any of his starring vehicles he
gets out pretty clean most of the time
except for when kurt russell is
headlining your movie in executive
decision seagal is the leader of a
badass special ops unit and he's got
some choice kicks kills and thrills but
one of his most iconic moments of his
entire career is when he reminded us
that even he is a mere mortal and he
sacrifices himself in order to keep the
mission afloat then in films like above
the law on deadly ground and the glimmer
man he returns to his bread and butter
beating people up and making it look so
so easy while doing it i don't even know
if the dude's heart rate gets elevated
by
anything boring
certainly not the case for jean-claude
van damme he should be on broadway with
those kicks but they come at a cost the
dude takes a licking during the majority
of his big time battles bloodsport lived
up to its name and features more
protagonist getting horn moments than in
steven seagal's entire filmography
bloodsport would also mark the first
time that us audiences were treated to
his preternatural splits maneuver during
a fight scene but it certainly wasn't
the last just ask these thugs from the
future time cop has him waking up with a
wicked hangover just in time to take on
some bad dudes entering his home but
before you go saying that anyone who
drank themselves to sleep at night
couldn't possibly do the splits on their
kitchen counter the next morning
remember this
it's the future and we don't know what
sort of miracle hangover drug will be
available by the year 2004. uh i miss
when the future was that steven seagal's
best movie might feature the lion's
share of kick-ass memorable moments as
well
under siege could be the best die-hard
rip-off ever and yes i'm looking at you
speed and it's because the film is
perfectly tailored to what steven seagal
does best
cook
not food but more evil doers in close
quarters combat being on a navy ship
means you get a lot of tight corners and
stevie's wonderful aikido prowess is the
perfect compliment to this scenario that
i am sir there's a great kitchen fight
an epic climax where tommy lee jones
skull sees just how dense it is and even
on the top deck some killer kicks and
quick hits
i also cook van damme looks to match
with his best movie at least according
to 8th grade mark ellis hard target john
woo and van damme might not have always
seen eye to eye during the production
but the director's slo-mo signature
proved to be the perfect marriage with
van damme's balletic fighting style the
spin kicks are cool the arrows are
deadly but nothing tops kicking a
henchman off of his motorcycle dukes of
hazaring yourself over a car
and then for equal parts badassery and
giggles witness chance boudreaux goes
surfing on the same motorcycle moments
later how did no bullets hit him
he blocked him i don't know but all
those horrible shot villains and hard
target have a bright future as an
imperial stormtrooper
all right so it's still a pretty close
race so let's get silly i'll stay in
these two franchises and for hard target
he punches a rattlesnake to sleep in
order to set a booby trap you laugh but
do you have any idea how hard it is to
pop a deadly snake hard enough to make
it fall asleep but not so hard as to
kill it oh and then don't forget to bite
the rattle off it'll be covered by cause
hmo
cigar salinas may not involve nature so
we'll swap out snakes and put in
horrific crash test dummies under siege
too dark territory takes place at night
but it still wasn't dark enough to mask
this fall that is supposed to look like
a human but more resembles a sad sack of
potatoes the movie was so bad by that
point i wonder if the producers wedged
this moment in there just to lighten the
mood on set and just listen to me and do
what i say but truly great sequences
aren't just the result of brawn
sometimes they're arrived at by seeing
our strapping hero become vulnerable
seagal shows glimpses of this inflicts
like executive decision and exit wounds
but jcbd gives a transcendental
monologue in the accurately titled film
jcvd that made us all wonder wait a
minute has this guy always been a great
actor and we just never noticed very
good use of intelligence
it's so deeply powerful and emotional
that one wonders what might have been if
van damme wasn't so busy running around
hong kong as twin brothers trying to
keep their family name clean
there's two of them man double impact is
awesome as is jean-claude's acting
ability from time to time but in the
meantime his cinematically charged fight
scenes and occasional vulnerability
are enough to give him the win in this
round and the muscles from brussels
takes a two to one lead over the guy
from the boat movie well that was cute
round four
get in the ring yep we're gonna stay in
the world of beating up hordes of
enemies but this round isn't about the
legendary movie moments they've produced
no it's the actual abilities showcased
by these two inarguably great martial
artists both van damme and seagal's
black belt have stories to tell so let's
get around the campfire and fire up some
marshmallows all working no play makes
jack a dull boy before they were doing
crazy make-em-ups on the big screen
jean-claude van damme and steven seagal
earned their way into tinseltown and
before that they earned their stripes as
dominant martial arts masters van damme
discovered karate at the age of 10 and
weightlifting soon thereafter focusing
on shotokan karate he trained
religiously at a local dojo and when his
father turned the family attic space
into a makeshift dojo the practice only
intensified hours of kicking a heavy bag
and intense stretching exercises gave
him a leg up on the local competition
and by the age of 12 he joined the
belgian center for karate training at
age 16 he joined the official team and
began competing in full contact
tournaments aren't you a little young
for full contact in fact they won the
european karate championships and his
lifetime record is 44 wins against just
four defeats now imagine the bragging
rights you get if you're one of those
four fellows who took down van dammage
you never have to buy a drink again i'm
sure steven seagal has black belts in
karate kendo and judo but is best known
for being a seventh dan black belt in
aikido which was developed in the early
part of the 1900s based on ancient
practices and translates into the way of
harmony of the spirit derived from
jujitsu it's a decidedly more
philosophical and ethical approach to
combat relying on self-defense
techniques that use an attacker's own
body weight and force against them the
strikes pins and especially joint
locking are evident in seagal's best big
screen brawls but long before he was a
household name at the tender age of 17
he moved to japan to learn more about
martial arts and he's credited as the
first foreigner to open their own aikido
studio in japan so the experts praised
the high level difficulty of jean-claude
van damme's karate moves and they've
fawned over his intense striking ability
but steven seagal seems to earn more
praise for his practical street smart
approach to dealing with situations
everything from seagal's movements to
his body posture were practiced with the
intent of dealing with these dilemmas
but he also employed swift sword
movements into his routine so you know
don't leave home without a sword i
believe you as impressive as all of van
damme's slo-mo high-fine karate is
seagal's relaxed takedowns of loads of
nerdwells is just as effective
which is why even though van damme was a
bouncer for a brief time at a joint
owned by wait for it
[Music]
chuck effing norris i give the edge to
seagal here simply because of all the
real martial artists that celebrate his
aikido and film van dam's moves
certainly look a lot prettier and are
more fun to try while jumping off the
couch or the diving board but in
practicality steven seagal's technique
is quicker less showy and ruthlessly
effective you want to impress the ladies
do a split kick you want to save your
own life go with seagal's takedowns in
the most controversial round probably in
the history of versus i'm giving steven
seagal the point
plus it ties the ball game and lets us
do one more round to decide once and for
all who is the best of the best i should
probably point out here that neither
steve or jean-claude actually star in
any of those best of the best karate
movies but uh they'll both be prominent
factors in the next round which is
the wild card round academy awards i kid
i kid both van damme and seagull they
have plenty of achievements to celebrate
but awards for motion picture excellence
have largely eluded them thus far in
fact the closest steven seagal came to
an acting academy award was at a
fictional oscar ceremony you remember
the kevin klein movie in and out so matt
dillon wins the award for the best lead
male performance one of his fellow
nominees that year and steven seagal for
snowball in hell
it's a solid joke but now let's get
serious these dudes aren't gunning for
praise amongst their cinematic peers
they're too busy you know saving the
world or at least the coast of hawaii or
getting revenge for their fallen brother
regardless of the task at hand both
action legends are always up for the
challenge i've enjoyed their movies for
decades so now to decide the winner in
the most important episode of versus
ever i'm gonna put myself in harm's way
i have to decide which movie theater i'm
walking into
your maniac
since you're no doubt a loyal viewer of
this hit program you might have seen me
pitch this scenario from time to time
you're at a theater and you have two
options screen one or screen two you
gotta walk into one and pick against the
other knowing nothing about either film
besides the fact that screen one is a
mystery van damme movie and screen 2 is
a mystery seagal movie
and yes i said it's a movie theater
which means this exercise will take
place in 1994 when both gents were at
the peak of their cinematic powers and
conveniently we have a way to get back
to that year thanks to the good folks at
the tec time cop the gift that keeps on
giving i'm never funny so which theater
do you enter steven seagal might be the
safer bet or at least you'll know what
kind of movie you're getting his films
back in the heyday never deviated too
far off the beaten path of a cop or a
military officer or a special ops
frogman faced with downing bad guys in a
race against time so you'll walk in with
seagal kicking ass as a given the
question is whose ass is he going to be
kicking at the climax it could be a
quality antagonist like a tommy lee
jones a william sadler or even a michael
kane who i totally forgot was the arch
enemy in on deadly ground until i
rewatched it for research purposes you
see kids
work can be fun yeah that's what i hear
with van damme the unknown factor is
what the hell is this movie going to be
about sure you're bound to get some a
plus karate action and a bevy of high
flying kicks but will it be him as a
drifter protecting a family like you
know where to run or will he be a cop
from the future or possibly even on the
ice during a pivotal stanley cup finals
hockey match you know for all the love
under siege gets is the best die hard
film not named die hard sudden death
deserves an honorable mention gambling
on hockey in vegas is a tricky
proposition but one thing you can bet on
is that steven seagal is gonna be
playing a hero he really only stepped
outside that mold once as he was
featured as the main batty to danny
trejo's hero in the spoof e machete but
john claude van damme could certainly
end up surprising you and being the
villain himself one of his earliest
roles was as a drago-tastic evil doer in
no retreat no surrender and he proved he
still has the best spin kick in the biz
with his naughty turn in expendables too
and speaking of those elegant moves that
might be where the kid in me leans
towards van damme and the adult i am
today agrees it's just cool to watch
that action on the big screen
seagal earned his point in the fighting
round but if paying money for a ticket
popcorn and soda is what i'm doing then
what i'm wanting is awesome looking
martial artistry that i'll try to
replicate at home and end up pulling a
groin you have to see it to believe it
if we don't get a ton of action for
whatever reason and the mystery films
rely on beast on my heart plot
jcvd also gets the nod just look at the
film jcbd he actually got oscar buzz for
this role i joke a lot on this show but
that wasn't a yuck yuck folks were
actually that impressed with how
emotional and introspective jean-claude
got even at the expense of his own
career i wouldn't complain about seeing
one or ten or more steven seagal movies
in his prime but i'm not sure i'd be
able to differentiate them all that much
afterwards hard to kill march for death
out for justice cool titles but they all
feel like the same film regardless of
the tomato meter report van damme flicks
each had their own flavor and
personality which is why after five
hard-fought rounds it is my great honor
to bestow jean-claude camille francois
van verenberg better known as
jean-claude van damme with definitely
not his greatest honor a win in this
round and thus the match on today's
episode of verses
i'm blown away
not to tell tales out of school but this
question of who would win in a fight has
been brewing in all of our brains for so
long and lo and behold the internet has
granted us at least a rumor of how close
of fisticuffs between van damme and
segal actually came to be it was at a
star-studded party thrown by
sylvester stallone and both of our
action movie titans were on hand van
damme had gotten win that seagal was
going around telling partygoers that he
could take jean no problem so what did
van damme do he and his twin brother
oh right that was double impact sorry i
get excited just van damme went up to
seagal and offered to take it outside
and settle the score once and for all
seagal made a hasty exit but later that
night van dam spotted seagal again and
repeated the offer seagal again refused
now i do know enough to know that when
someone on steven seagal's level refuses
to fight it might just be to save the
life of his opponent but in this case it
seems like van damme had the upper hand
and stallone when asked about this near
miss also felt like jean-claude would
have won way back when in 1996
or 1997. i was meaning to tell you
i really don't like you now maybe sly
favored van damme because jean-claude
took him up on an offer to appear in an
expendable while seagal apparently asked
for too much money and given the
landscape of pay-per-view fighting maybe
we could see this matchup one day but
perhaps it is better left to our own
imagination and today van damme gets the
win from me a kid who had a hard target
banner not a poster you heard me right a
banner in his bedroom growing up but now
it's your turn who's the best in your
opinion hit me up on social media at
mark ellis live and let the electronic
fist fly this has been the joy of my
career to host stay tuned for a bunch
more verses and thank you sincerely for
supporting our show and getting us to
this mountaintop
it sounds like i'm retiring but i'm not
i'm just really really excited about
this episode my name is mark ellis and
hunting season
isn't
you